ist es angst ist ascom panait dass so
viele menschen in russland schweigen
schweigen müssen schweigen golden
kriegsherr platini putin hat offenbar
wenig zu befürchten von der eigenen
bevölkerung auf wenn die sanktionen und
isolation des landes immer spürbarer
werden seine tyrannei scheint perfekt
organisiert kaum jemand kann sich im
moment vorstellen mit diesem system über
frieden und verständigung zu verhandeln
obwohl dieser zeitpunkt kommen wird
putins krieg wie umgehen mit russland
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet sind wladimir
kaminer schriftsteller und kolumnist sie
sind gibt wirklich aus moskau und man
kennt sie als autor von büchern wie
militärmusik oder russendisko auch
zugeschaltet ist anke giesen vom
vorstand von memorial deutschland und
memorial international memorial ist ein
noch zu sowjetzeiten gegründete
menschenrechtsorganisation die sich vor
allen dingen mit der stalinistischen
vergangenheit in der sowjetunion
befasst hat aber natürlich jetzt auch
aktuellen anlass hat über
menschenrechtsverletzungen
nachzudenken hier im studio ist
professorin aus einer schröder und die
wissenschaftlerinnen und sie sind die
direktorin am institut für
friedensforschung und sicherheitspolitik
der universität hamburg schließlich
gemma pörzgen
chefredakteurin der zeitschrift ost west
europäische perspektiven und sie sind
auch vorstandsmitglied von reporter ohne
grenzen herr kaminer was ist es was so
viele russinnen und russen gerade
beseelt ist es angst ist es kompanie mit
putin oder ist es eine mischung aus
beiden
ich weiß dass meine freunde sehr
darunter leiden vor allem diejenigen die
eine sehr große wut auch das geschrieben
haben und das land aber nicht verlassen
können oder auch nicht wollen das ist
auf jeden fall keine kampagne ich glaube
für die meisten
der russen ist einfach diese vorstellung
unerträglich
wie wollen sie in einem land leben
das und präsidieren ein mörder ist
das ist einfach also sie suchen
krankhaft nach
jede möglichkeit nicht daran zu glauben
und sagen nein die lage ist nicht
eindeutig weil wenn das eindeutig ist
wie sollen sich die bürger was was
können sie tun wir sollen sie sich
überhaupt
dazu äußern
so schröder
wir bereden gleich weiter wladimir
kaminer frau schröder setzt für einen
winzigen lichtblick müssten ja erstmal
die waffen schweigen sind wir da noch
sehr weit davon entfernt von diesem
zeitpunkt das ist schwer zu sagen der
ist wird in jedem fall gerade nicht um
friedensverhandlungen gehen sondern wenn
überhaupt um einen waffenstillstand
vielleicht auch keinen umfassenden
waffenstillstand und selbst für solche
verhandlungen braucht man zwei parteien
momentan können wir noch nicht erkennen
dass putin diese verhandlungen anstrebt
das kann aber in mittelfristig auch in
den nächsten wochen schon anders werden
wo gießen ungefähr zehntausend menschen
haben in russland ihren mut gegen den
krieg zu protestieren mit ihrer freiheit
bezahlt was wird mit gießen menschen
diesen 14.000 verhafteten wohl passieren
das ist im moment noch ganz schwer
abzusehen also dass der staat geht
unglaublich willkürlich vor einige
menschen werden vielleicht in ein paar
tagen oder paar monaten einfach
entlasten gegen andere werden
gerichtsverfahren angestrengt aufgrund
dieses neuen gesetzes dass bestimmte
jetzt ja zum beispiel verboten das wort
krieg zu benutzen für das was in der
ukraine ab geht und es kann sein dass da
bis zu 15 jährige haftstrafe bei
rauskommen also es wird garantiert an
einigen leuten harte exempel
statuiert ist die russische gesellschaft
eigentlich vollständig abgeschnitten von
unabhängigen informationen oder kann
sehen wer sehen will was wir in der
ukraine gerade vor sich geht also es ist
natürlich sehr eingeschränkt worden also
vor allem jetzt auch noch mal in den
letzten wochen aber wer sozusagen wissen
will kann natürlich sich immer noch
informieren also es gibt die möglichkeit
über vpn eben sich immer noch ein zu
wählen in das internet und auch alle
medien zu konsumieren
und youtube funktioniert noch also wer
mehr gesehen dass facebook blockiert ist
und ich glaube ich funktioniert auch
noch ob auch genau und und telegramm
also es gibt immer noch kanäle aber ich
glaube der entscheidende unterschied ist
eben es muss aktiv jemand darauf
zugreifen und die meisten menschen sind
ja doch eher passive konsumenten von
medien und da haben eben die
staatsmedien die größte rolle das könnt
ihr aber so was wie stille post auch
geben dass das eben weitergetragen wird
es auch das stadt sie ist gerade nicht
jeder einen zugang zu whatsapp zumindest
die älteren nicht
das wissen wir einfach nicht so genau
also es gibt keine eindeutigen um fragen
die uns wirklich verraten sollten wie
die menschen über diesen krieg denken
sie müssen sich auch klar machen dass
gerade ältere menschen die in der
sowjetunion groß geworden sind auch
leute sind bei denen natürlich jetzt
eine angst zurück kehrt auch immer
stärker sich zu äußern aber ich
persönlich glaube schon dass viele
wissen dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt
unsere vermutung und auch staatliche
umfragen ausrufen sagen ja dass
mindestens zwei drittel hinter putin und
seinem krieg stehen ist es richtig kann
sich putin auf die loyalität seiner
untertanen verlassen denn die sieht ja
wohl als seine untertanen an ich sagte
ja gerade das muss nicht so genau es
gibt keine eindeutigen umfragen also es
gibt natürlich all diese ausnahmen zum
beispiel vom samstag aus dem stadion es
gab gibt schon diese staatlich gelenkten
umfragen aber ob das auch ihr eindruck
ist dass das durchaus richtig ist dass
wir auf diese sie sagten ja sind
staatlich gelenkte umfragen damit sind
es für mich keine fragen auf die man
sich verlassen kann es gibt auch eine
umfrage abhängiges umfrageinstitut
levada das deutet auch darauf hin dass
es einen rückhalt gibt in der
bevölkerung aber ich würde davor waren
sozusagen sich auf solche ergebnisse zu
verlassen irgendwie weil wir es de facto
einfach gar nicht wissen und die
erfahrung zeigt aber dass natürlich
bestimmte dinge zu menschen durchdringen
und das sind natürlich vor allem die
vielen vielen toten soldaten das ist
glaube ich etwas wenn das in den
familien durchsickert das ist dann nicht
nur stille post wie sie das genannt
haben sondern eben einfach ein trauriges
erzählen unter freunden und das erfährt
man sicherlich von
diesen beim umgang mit seinen gegnern
wie jetzt auch ned er heute noch mal
neun jahre aufgebrummt bekommen hat
unter verschärften bedingungen in einem
arbeitslager zu bringen zu müssen beim
umgang zu entgegnen hat er ja offenbar
im moment freie hand wird wird denn
diese repression noch zunehmend vor
allen dingen wenn der krieg aus seiner
sicht schlecht verläuft
davon ist auszugehen und die kollegen
jetzt in moskau haben auch deshalb
entschieden also viele von ihnen das
land zu verlassen weil
wirklich befürchtet wird dass also diese
repressionen jetzt zugeben dass zu
nehmen immer mehr menschen verhaftet
werden und auch immer härtere strafen
ausgesprochen werden
tamina warum hat sich denn der besten
besonders deutschland solange einer
illusion über putin hingegeben ging es
dann nur ums erdgas oder kommt diese
illusion putin gegenüber auch noch von
etwas anderem her
ich weiß also ich glaube es also ich
habe mich das auch gefragt wissen sie
ich glaube dass diese
verschiebung in der reaktion einfach im
politischen betrieb
unsere demokratie
einfach drin steckt das ist also wie
reagieren immer
immer später
gerade in solchen zeiten
des krieges war die situation jeden tag
sich verändert
fehlt es besonders auf
und es sind vor allem vor allem frage
ich mich wozu diese diese ständige
wiederholung dass wir uns nicht
einmischen dass wir auf gar keinen fall
eine seite in diesem konflikt
annehmen wir mischen uns doch schon
längst ein wie liefern waffen und nizon
ukrainische flugzeuge starten von
polnischen landebahnen wir sind auch ein
teil dieses konfliktes denn von putin
angekündigte krieg ist nicht exakt gegen
die ukraine gerichtet sondern ist als
kreuzzug gegen den westen gegen
europäische werte
eingerichtet
was war soll dann diese aussage dass wir
uns da raus halten wo es doch gegen uns
gerichtet ist an den ist diese aussage
heilig ist dass ein boden gerichtet um
ihn zu ermutigen weiterzumachen
ich verstehe das nicht auch mit diesen
öllieferungen also jetzt darauf zu
bestehen von dem feind
[Musik]
zu bekommen das ist ich weiß ja
wahrscheinlich wird diese entscheidung
dann endgültig fallen
wenn wenn wenn russische panzer editor
in meck-pomm dann
hier rumfahren das hat also diese
aussage wir hätten putin zu lange
gewähren lassen haben die ihnen 2014 vor
allen dingen nach der annexion der kind
vielleicht sogar unfreiwillig ermuntert
mit unserem verhalten trifft den westen
auch eine erhebliche mitschuld am
ausbruch des krieges gegen die ukraine
außenpolitik verläuft ja in längeren
linien und wir haben in der in der
deutschen außenpolitik gegenüber
russland sehr lange gesehen dass putin
gewährten gewährt wohl dass er auch
expansionistische motive durchaus
plausibel darlegen konnte aber eben
nicht so wirklich geglaubt wurde und
dass er in verschiedenen kleineren
feldzügen und auch in
interaktionen auf unserem territorium
denken sie an die kripo wurde
beispielsweise
interveniert hat in ein souveränes
territorium eines anderen staates aber
wie heirat vorspiel gewesen es war eine
art vorspiel aber man braucht natürlich
in der außenpolitik auch das politische
momentum politikwandel umsetzen zu
können und das habe ich 2014 noch nicht
gesehen eine breite europäische front um
dieser politik einhalt zu gebieten habe
ich nicht gesehen und halte ich auch für
unwahrscheinlich dass es dazu gekommen
wäre zu dem zeitpunkt würden sie denn
der einschätzung von wladimir kaminer
zustimmen dass es weniger um die ukraine
geht als vielmehr um einen kreuzzug
gegen den westen
ich würde der analyse zustimmen dass es
nicht nur um die ukraine geht ich würde
aber nicht der analyse zustimmen dass es
momentan um
die in die abwehr von russischen panzern
in mecklenburg vorpommern geht es dann
es geht bei der diskussion um das
raushalten aus dem konflikt geht es im
prinzip eine risikoabwägung also um die
frage wie können wir in diesem konflikt
und so verhalten durch verschiedene
mechanismen abschreckung
sanktionspolitik härtester gangart um zu
verhindern dass dieser konflikt in der
ukraine dieser angriffskrieg in eine
nukleare eskalation entgleitet und dafür
gibt es ganz harte risikoabwägungen die
sich dann darin ausdrücken dass die nato
sagt wir gehen bis hierhin aber keinen
schritt weiter damit russland diese
eskalation nicht herbeiführen kann dann
kommen die eskalation ja dadurch am
besten vermeiden die man irgendwann mal
eben zu verhandlungen kommt damit es
erst gar nicht zu dieser eskalation am
ende kommt was braucht es eigentlich um
putin an den verhandlungstisch zu
bringen es wird ja die ganze zeit
gesprochen also ich würde auch gerne
noch mal ein paar schritte zurück und
noch mal also sowohl ihrem satz von den
illusionen als auch der darstellung
widersprechen dass da nichts passiert
seit 2014 es war ganz klar als
völkerrechtswidrig die krippen zu
annektieren und auch damals gab es schon
sanktion und es gab auch eine einhellige
ansicht also vor allem hier in der in
deutschland in der bundesregierung aber
auch weitgehend in der europäischen
union das dass dieses verhalten
sozusagen eine auch schon eine
zeitenwende war man kann darüber
streiten ob die maßnahmen die danach
ergriffen wurden ausgereicht haben und
aber ich war ein bisschen erstaunt jetzt
zu hören da sei nichts passiert das ist
glaube ich falsch und ich würde auch
gerne vor allem einen wichtigen satz den
sie gesagt hatten herr kaminer
korrigieren weil sie sprachen davon dass
von polnischen flughäfen luft rakete und
klinische luft raketen fliegen das das
nicht sondern ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig auch damit hier beim zuschauer
nicht ein falscher eindruck entsteht das
ist eben genau diese feine linie die man
versucht ja zu beachten von der sie auch
sprachen dass man eben im moment in
diesem moralischen dilemma ist eben das
nicht zu einem nato fall werden zu
lassen sondern eben die ukraine sehr
wohl zu unterstützen mit allen
möglichkeiten die man hat aber den
konflikt natürlich nicht so weit zu
eskalieren
dass wir gegebenenfalls eben in eine
situation kommen die wir gar nicht mehr
zu beherrschen wissen kann ich sage
nochmal platz sehen und sie sagen seid
2014 hat sich schon einiges getan es
gibt ja tatsächlich da auch gab es ja
auch sanktionen gegen russland aber wann
sie sind sie nicht folgenlos geblieben
das würde ich nicht sagen also es gab
damals ja prognosen die sagten der wäre
damals schon weiter marschiert hätte man
keine sanktion gehabt und ich finde auch
nicht dass man den autoritären kurs die
in russland genommen hat in den letzten
jahren übersehen hätte das kann ich
alles nicht erkennen die frage war halt
wie geht man damit um das ist ja eine
sehr wichtige frage die uns auch weiter
beschäftigen wird wie gehen wir mit
systemen um in denen eben keine
demokratie herrscht sondern eben willkür
und rechtlosigkeit und trotzdem müssen
wir ja miteinander sprechen und deswegen
finde ich persönlich zum beispiel auch
wichtig dass es immer noch telefonate
gibt mit putin dass man auch versucht
sozusagen auf dem laufenden zu bleiben
darüber was er plant und denkt da hört
man das ist offenbar eine
radikalisierung auch zu beobachten ist
im gespräch mit ihm das kann ich ja nur
so wiedergeben wir sind ja alle bei
diesen gesprächen nicht dabei und es
gibt ja auch diese verhandlungen bei
denen sich tatsächlich unter
hintertreffen und versuchen schon über
mögliche lösungen zu sprechen die
forderungen von siemens die das ist
tatsächlich zu einem treffen zwischen
ihm und putin kommen könnte ist
wahrscheinlich etwas
ich vermag mir das noch nicht vorstellen
nicht angesichts der der schrecknisse
die wir in der ukraine sehen und aber
wer weiß was die nächsten wochen bringen
also wir haben auch vor wenigen wochen
nicht uns vorstellen können dass wir da
sind wo wir jetzt sind der umgang mit
dem krieg frau gießen das lehrt uns
jetzt
also umgang mit putin das lehrt uns
jetzt gerade der krieg die frage war ja
was bringt ihn an den verhandlungstisch
muss man die sanktionen noch verschärfen
ein totales energie embargo
beschlagnahmungen von
oligarchen also putin a legal im besten
verstärkte noch verstärkte waffen dieser
ring möglicherweise sogar den total
abbruch aller handelsbeziehungen
ich weiß gar nicht ob man gut ihn
wirklich an den verhandlungstisch
bekommen kann also mein eindruck ist von
dem also wenn man seine reden liest dann
hat er ein ganz bestimmtes ziel im kopf
und das will er durchsetzen und ich
glaube der jets auch die situation in
der ukraine bis jetzt nicht wirklich
realistisch ein erscheint auch nicht
wirklich realistisch von seinen beratern
gebrieft zu werden
man sagt ja auch dass seine berater auch
im vorhinein ihm geschönte berichte
gegeben haben aus gutem grund teil
werden die berichte anders lauteten als
er sie gern gehabt hätten
haben die sozusagen dann ja auch
massiven stress gekriegt also mein
eindruck ist dass er einfach wirklich
abgekoppelt von der welt in einem raum
agiert und
gar nicht einsieht dass es dazu was zu
verhandeln gibt und das ist dass er auch
keinen plan b hat also dass er
letztendlich wirklich in einer sackgasse
steckt und ja und und das macht mir
eigentlich große sorgen also dass man
weil man einfach nicht weiß wie die wird
er weiter reagieren wird es zum
chemiewaffen einsetze
com und/oder
können wir darauf hoffen dass ihn jemand
aus seinem engeren kreis einfach
irgendwann neutralisiert also im moment
ich kann mir wirklich keine
verhandlungslösung vorstellen ein
schöner ist es denkbar dass die jetzt
von frau gewesen angedeutet die berater
von putin ihnen auf angst sozusagen ins
offene messer haben laufen lassen was
die zustände der ukraine angeht die
reaktion der bevölkerung und das ist
jetzt aus diesen
gewünschten blitzkrieg nichts wird in
personalisierten autokratien und oder
diktaturen kann so etwas vorkommen dass
der entscheidungs der kreis von
entscheidungs personen um eine leitungs
figur so klein ist dass dort group senkt
miss information passieren das kann in
diesem fall auch der fall gewesen sein
es ist schon relativ schwer darüber zu
spekulieren
und ich denke auch dass
verhandlungslösungen
unausweichlich sind auf lange sicht weil
wir aus der forschung zu kriegen auch
wissen dass diese dass die kriegsführung
selbst einfluss darauf hat wie die
führung einer kriegspartei
schaden und nutzen gegeneinander abwägt
wenn putin sieht dass wir auf der einen
seite einen lang andauernden geringer
krieg aufstandsbekämpfung in der ukraine
vor uns haben was durchaus der fall sein
kann das sind die prognosen zu zeiten
auf der anderen seite
wirtschaftssanktionen irgendwann doch
innenpolitisch destabilisieren dann wird
auch ein putin einlenken zu einem
verhandlungsergebnis zu kommen
jedenfalls ist es das was unsere
bisherige forschung aus der
konfliktforschung forschung zu kriegs
beendigung sagt das heißt erfolgreichen
installationen vor allem konsequente
sanktionen könnten durchaus zu einem
ziel führen über zeit die wirkungs logik
von sanktionen ist mittelfristig nicht
kurzfristig man kann nicht reingehen und
sagen in zwei wochen nach sanktionen
haben wir das kriegsende sind es geht
darum mittelfristig verhaltens
änderungen herbeizuführen und das nicht
als strafaktion zu verstehen sondern als
anreizstruktur das heißt unter welchen
bedingungen sind akteure bereits
sanktionen wieder aufzuheben und das
wäre der anreiz mit dem man
gegebenenfalls putin mittelfristig
wieder zum verhandlungstisch bekommt
dann kam ich nach sie haben gerade
gesagt das sei auch ein
verdrängungsprozess bei den russinnen
und dass sie sehen was da jetzt passiert
was putin im russischen namen anstellt
kann es sein denn dieser krieg länger
dauert wenn er noch mehr grausamkeiten
erzeugt aber auch für viele russen noch
mehr entbehrungen dass sich diese
stimmung auch wandelt im land
ich bin mir absolut sicher dass die
stimmung auch viel schneller wandel teil
als wir uns vorstellen können
es sind ja sehr sehr viele menschen
umgekommen in der ukraine sehr viele
soldaten und diese menschen fehlen das
kann man nicht durch propaganda ersetzen
also diese leeren betten in den
russischen kasernen also diese die reste
der russischen armee die jetzt
irgendwann mal nach hause gehen um das
auch eben weitergeben das wird schon
eine sehr starke
eine eine sehr starke wirkung haben auch
die gesellschaft ich möchte nur kurz
zurück greifen auf das vorhergesagte ich
meinte nicht dass irgendwelche raketen
starten von europäischem territorium
nach meinen erkenntnissen sind die lande
fahren und für die flugzeuge in der
ukraine zerstört und die landebahnen
meinte ich voll von von dem
nachbarland ich möchte nur ganz kurz nur
noch zu der außenpolitischen stellung
deutschlands
anmerken
wir sollen uns darüber gedanken machen
finde ich sollte putin diese
angriffskrieg dieses öffentliche
abschlachten der ukraine vor augen der
welt
gelingen woran ich nicht glaube und
das auch natürlich nicht wie aber sollte
es der fall sein
dann wäre die
das ansehen der eu
dauerhaft sehr sehr stark geschädigt das
wäre
ein politisches bankrott für die
europäische union und für die nato
das wäre genau so eine niederlage für
uns wie für die ukrainer wenn es möglich
ist heute auf europäischen kontinent ein
großes land
dermaßen zu dem mutigen so in die knie
zu zwingen dann sind alle
anderen lernen da hier auch nicht mal
ein wenig wir
das glauben sie wenn es tatsächlich so
weit käme dass die ukraine militärische
unterliegt dass russland das land
dauerhaft zu mindestens in wichtigen
teilen besetzt was bedeutet das für die
europäische union die da nicht so helfen
konnte wie man es vielleicht wollte um
das zu verhindern was bedeutet eine
militärische niederlage der ukraine für
westeuropa überhaupt für den westen ich
bin nicht so ein freund von solchen
spekulationen für die zukunft ich würde
sagen dann sich aber wenn man sich die
jetzige lage anguckt ist ja eher ganz im
gegenteil so dass wir beobachten dass
die russische armee keinesfalls so stark
ist wie prognostiziert also vorher ging
man ja sehr selbstverständlich davon aus
dass die ukraine sozusagen verlieren
würden im moment ist es ja so dass wir
beobachten dass die ganze modernisierung
der russischen armee offenbar so
großartig nicht gewesen ist wie man
behauptet hat und vor allem wir einen
großen kampfgeist sehen bei der
ukrainischen armee und das leben nicht
nur die unterstützung ist von von den
partnern des westens sondern eben auch
das land selbst dass sich dazu wieder
stehen weiß und sofern kann ich mir so
ein szenario wie sie das andeuten kaum
vorstellen zumal wir ja vorhin von den
sanktionen sprachen und ich gar nicht
glaube dass das nur eine mittelfristige
wirkung hat weil man ja jetzt schon
sieht das in russland die ganzen ersten
maßnahmen sehr große wirkung zu
eigentlich also es ist sozusagen vom
zahlungsverkehr weitgehend abgekoppelt
die leute können gar nicht mehr geld
abheben die inflation ist groß ich habe
ein interessantes eine interessante
sendung gesehen mit einer wirtschafts
ökonomen die ratschläge gab an die
russische bevölkerung
was man denn jetzt alles tun wirst du
sowieso mit medikamenten absichern für
die nächsten neuen weil man die in eben
nicht mehr bekommt und das werden die
leute alles schon merken irgendwie die
für deutschen firmen also nicht nur die
deutschen von sonne und viele firmen
sind abgezogen ob das nun mcdonald's ist
der mitten in moskau geschlossen ist und
h&m ich glaube das bringt viele menschen
zum nachdenken und ich glaube dass wir
diese wirkungen von sanktionen die ja so
stark jetzt auch
konzipiert sind wie wir das eigentlich
noch nirgendwo erlebt haben die sollten
wir erst mal abwarten bevor wir
szenarien zeichnen wie das ihren gut das
war jetzt eine frage gewesen ob das
denkbar ist ein weiteres problem für
russland könnte ja der ungeheure
blutzoll auch sein den offensichtlich
die armee erleidet blutiger ganze
division aus kann das richtig
demoralisieren die wirkungen noch haben
auf die gesellschaft ähnlich wie die
sanktionen die sie grade skizziert haben
ich könnte mir das vorstellen also wir
lesen ja auch dass zum beispiel
komponenten fehlen jetzt schon für für
panzer also fragt man sich wie lange
fahren die dann auch wenn die
komponenten fehlen oder wir sprechen
immer sehr viel jetzt über russland und
ukraine belarus spielt ja auch zum
beispiel eine wichtige rolle da kommen
viele der leichen und der verletzten
russischen soldaten an man hat da auch
die auflagen darüber nicht zu sprechen
aber das spricht sich natürlich herum
und eine entscheidende frage der
nächsten zeit wird sein ob denn er ist
in diesen krieg mit eintritt bisher ist
noch kein einziger russischer soldat
über die grenze gegangen es gibt
natürlich es ist aufmarschgebiet für das
russische militär und von dort wird auch
die ukrainische territorium geschossen
aber es gibt in belarus eben einen
großen willen sich an diesem krieg zu
beteiligen
und eben auch sogar was man hört auch in
der armee und dann insofern sind also
eine 5 von faktoren die da durchaus dazu
beitragen können dass dieser plan von
putin überhaupt nicht aufgeht so ließen
es gibt ja auch ab kopplungs versuche
oder auch richtige abkopplung zum
beispiel von russischer kultur ein
beispiel ist ja der münchner
chefdirigent valery gergiew wie wie
sehen sie das eigentlich das ist es auch
diesen kulturellen bereich betrifft dass
man sich so ein stück weit von russland
auch kulturell distanziert
also ich sehe jetzt eigentlich nicht
dass man sich von russland kulturellen
distanziert also vor allen dingen gibt
es ja auch jede menge
gegenkultur also jetzt in dem sinne also
auch oppositionelle kultur und viele
russische künstler sind ja auch aus dem
grund aus russland ausgereist also man
wird vielleicht wieder wie auch nach der
revolution was so eine art enge bande
mit mit russischer kultur in der
emigration haben also von da aus dieser
sorge habe ich nicht also wir verdanken
viel russische kultur auch eben
emigranten wie chagall oder kandinsky
nabokov
also ich glaube da sind eigentlich die
verbindungen so tief dass das dass man
russland sich von der europäischen
kultur abkoppeln kann also da sagen wir
mal die russische kultur man kann
natürlich sagen wir mal wieder eine art
eiserner vorhang zu diesem land
errichten aber
es wird weiter kulturellen austausch und
kanäle geben da habe ich eigentlich
keine sorgen der kamin viele prominente
kulturschaffende russland sind ja jetzt
tatsächlich im ausland lebenden ausland
oder sind in der letzten zeit emigriert
welche einflussmöglichkeit haben denn
diese ja zum teil sehr prominenten
künstlerinnen und künstler auf die
entwicklung auf die vorgänge in russland
soweit ich weiss vor allem die
journalisten die fast vollzählig
die heimat verlassen mussten wollen
jetzt von außen quasi einer eine
informationsquelle scharfen für ihre
landsleute
im inneren des landes sie und das ihnen
sie auf hilfe angewiesen hoffentlich
werden sie auch diese hilfe gekommen ich
bemühe mich da auch in dieser in dieser
richtung dass wir
selbst wenn die russen das ganze
internet abschalten eine möglichkeit
finden auf russland zu senden weil sie
trotz allem wissen was in der welt
passiert ist wie die wild auf russland
schaut das ist heute wichtig und das
wird auch für die zukunft russlands sehr
wichtig sein ich glaube nicht dass
dieses regime lange es lang geschafft
haben weil das auch einer der eine
unglaubliche zumutung ist man
kann nicht gegen die ganze welt sein nur
weil aus dem willen eines einzigen
mannes ja
deswegen also denke ich jetzt schon an
die zukunft da an die zeit nach guten
plätzen genau ich wollte das gerne
ergänzen und die gedanken von herrn
camina weil wir bei reporter ohne
grenzen natürlich in ganz engen kontakt
stehen zu den kollegen die tatsächlich
in scharen das land verlassen haben
bereits oder verlassen das sind ganze
redaktionen die gegangen sind weil eben
nicht nur durch die blockierung ihrer
arbeit sondern auch dadurch dass die
geschäftsmodelle die ja funktioniert nun
zerstört wurden sie im land nicht mehr
arbeiten können und wir werden in den
nächsten tagen zusammen mit der
schöpflin stiftung und der aufstand
stiftung und anderen deutschen
stiftungen und
journalistenorganisationen
einen fond eröffnen für exil
journalismus der sich genau diese
anliegen widmen wird weil wir im moment
beobachten ist es eine fülle von
aktivitäten gibt in deutschland wo man
eben von verlagsseite von stiftungs
seite helfen will um eben aus dem exil
heraus strukturen zu schaffen die eben
helfen können informationen in russland
weiter bereit zu stellen und wir wollen
eben in diesem fonds diese arbeit
stärker kanalisieren um eben dann das
auch zusammenzuführen mit dem schicksal
der belarussischen
journalisten die das ganze ja auch schon
erlebt haben nach der niederschlagung
der proteste in belarus in der ukraine
ist es so dass wir journalisten bisher
im land helfen weil die meisten dort
bleiben und weiter tapfer arbeiten wir
haben dort ein medienzentrum gegründet
berg stellen schutzwesten und helme zur
verfügung da ist eine etwas andere
situation aber es gilt wirklich im
moment sehr unbedingt irgendwie auch
gerade den russischen und bella
russischen kollegen zu helfen und bei
den belarussischen kollegen muss man
sich auch noch einmal klarmachen dass
viele schwierigkeiten haben in die
europäische union zu kommen weil sie
eben kein schengen visum haben also
viele wählen jetzt erstmal den weg über
die blitze oder
genau oder über armenien oder sind in
istanbul gestrandet insofern wird das
bei uns auch ein europäisches projekt um
diese leute zusammenzuführen und auch zu
ermöglichen dass sie über grenzen hinweg
in ihren redaktionen arbeiten können
verschulter es gab ja nicht nur einen
regen kulturellen austausch mit russland
sondern auch einen wissenschaftlichen
austausch zu ihrem bereich zum beispiel
leidet der jetzt auch unter dem krieg ja
die großen wissenschaftsorganisationen
die universitäten die
wissenschaftseinrichtungen haben den
kontakt zu russischen institutionen fast
vollständig abgebrochen es sollen keine
gelder mehr aus der forschung in die
forschung nach russland fließen und das
beeinträchtigt
langjährige jahrzehntelange
wissenschafts kooperationen massiv und
da ist die frage zu welchem ziel tun wir
das eigentlich weil wir wissen dass
sowohl kulturelle interaktion
zivilgesellschaftliche interaktion
wissenschaftliche interaktionen im
positiven sinne der nährboden sind für
zukünftige
koexistenz vertrauensbildung
friedensförderung über die nächsten
jahrzehnte und dass diese
die diese
vorfeldorganisationen diese
wissenschaftlichen organisationen in der
lage sind kontakte zu halten die man auf
der politischen ebene gerade nicht
halten kann während des kalten krieges
wissen wir dass über austauschprogramme
50.000 so wie jetzt in den usa waren
zwischen den 50er und 80er jahren und
umgekehrt genauso viele gewissen auch
das in europa diese formen der erasmus
austauschprogramm die alle studierenden
kennen die schüler und klassen austausch
mit frankreich und die
städtepartnerschaften dass das
befriedende maßnahmen nach dem ende des
zweiten weltkriegs waren die dazu führen
sollen dass durch direkte personelle
kommunikation und interaktion der boden
geschaffen wird für eine ein
kennenlernen und gegen eine entfremdung
zwischen
den völkern oder den staaten und die
wissenschaftskooperation war immer eine
solche brücke nach russland das trifft
auch bestimmte bereiche in der
naturwissenschaftlichen forschung jetzt
hart und für uns stellt sich halt die
frage wie lange kann man das
aufrechterhalten und wichtig ist dass
die kontakte zu individuellen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nicht abreißen das ist natürlich klar
dass man keine ressourcen drüber
schicken kann aber kooperation ist ein
strömungsabriss
wissenschaftlichen austausches führt
auch dazu dass die beziehungen zur
zivilgesellschaft letztendlich erodieren
oder vielleicht sogar zerstört werden
genau und das ist aus der konflikt
transformation kommend fatal weil wir
wissen dass wir diese kommunikation
diese interpersonelle beziehungen die
brauchen wir um später wieder aufbauen
zu können was wir hatten und die
wissenschaftskooperation mit russland
waren lange sehr stabil und sind immer
im hintergrund durchgelaufen auch
während des kalten krieges auch der
austausch zwischen einzelpersonen und da
würde mich interessieren was die
strategische planung ist aber es war
einfach ein fehler uns mal so zu sagen
ich halte das zum beispiel falsch also
so richtig die sanktionen sind habe ich
eben das gefühl dass wir an manchen
stellen über das ziel hinausschießen
auch die aufkündigung der
städtepartnerschaften halte ich auch in
fünf falschen wegen und
insofern gibt es daher zum teil auch
durchaus widerstand also höre ich
jedenfalls dass es bei wissenschaftlern
durchaus leute gibt die das kritisch
sehen es gibt auch einzelne
universitäten die das eigentlich gar
nicht mitgehen wollen und hoffe dass es
darüber mehr öffentliche debatten geben
wird wo es denn sinnvoll an vielen
stellen ja aber ich finde an diesen
stellen wo wir weiter brücken bauen
müssen und eben auch einfach in kontakt
bleiben mit den menschen die er nicht
alle in russland putin unterstützen
halte ich das enorm wichtig dass man
nicht alle brücken abbricht und das gilt
im übrigen zum beispiel auch für den it
bereich also da ist es so dass viele it
firmen jetzt
ihre russischen kunden und sozusagen
rausschmeißen und gar nicht darüber
nachdenken dass das eben zum teil
kritische plattform sind die davon mit
betroffen sind insofern ist an dieser
stelle glaube ich sehr viel kenntnis der
situation nötig und gute information um
zu unterscheiden an welcher stelle
machen wir auch fehler mit diesen
sanktionen wenn wir die zu breit
aufstellen vergießen wenn man jetzt hört
also da sind die individuellen kontakte
das ist städtepartnerschaften das sind
diese klassischen
klassische zivilgesellschaftliche ebene
was wir unter die zivilgesellschaft hier
bei uns verstehen ist dass in russland
noch intakt ist das noch vorhanden wie
muss man sich im moment die situation
dort vorstellen
das ist eine spannende frage also
zivilgesellschaft gibt es natürlich noch
in russland aber welche art von
zivilgesellschaft natürlich kann man
verein gründen und mit kindern in parks
blumen pflanzen oder man kann alte leute
im seniorenheim besuchen oder diese art
von zivilgesellschaft die
keinerlei also nicht nicht sonderlich
gesellschaftspolitisch aufgeladen ist
die ist natürlich möglich aber alle
jegliche form von zivilgesellschaft die
kritisch ist die an entscheidungen der
machthaber der in moskau oder auch in
den regionen rüttelt oder die in frage
stellt also im umweltschutzbereich im
menschenrechtsbereich wo es um
missstände im gesundheitswesen geht
diese form von
zivilgesellschaft wird ja immer enger
ist ja von dem russischen
geldquellen vollkommen abgeschnitten und
weil kein großes stiftung sich dann auch
traut den förderungen zu geben und ist
dann wenn sie ausländische förderung
erhält ja über das agenten gesetzt dann
total stigmatisiert
weil dieser die dieses diese markierung
ausländischer agent natürlich vor dem
hintergrund der stalinistischen
geschichte städten stigmatisierende
wirkung hat und sich menschen die sich
eher konform verhalten mit solchen
organisationen dann auch nicht einlassen
nicht stören veranstaltungen besucht
also in dem sinne
ich spiele jetzt auch nicht sagen dass
es falsch ist mit unpolitischer
zivilgesellschaft in kontakt zu bleiben
also ich denke es ist in jedem fall
wichtig dass man jungen menschen in
russland die möglichkeit gibt nach
europa zu kommen europa kennenzulernen
und ja hier praktika zu machen hier
soziales jahr oder umwelt jahre oder was
weiß ich zu machen einfach damit sie
auch eine erfahrung machen gesellschaft
kann auch anders funktionieren also die
gesellschaft in russland funktioniert
der camina muss man denn in der nach
putin ära diese zivilgesellschaft
praktische von grund auf wieder neu
errichten oder praktisch
ist ja sozusagen ein anfang ist dann
praktisch nichts da muss man da von
anfang an alles wieder neu organisieren
oder kann man dann möglicherweise auf
vorgehende strukturen noch zurückgreifen
was meinen sie
ich hoffe sehr dass nach dem dieser
ganze übel vorbei ist die augen der welt
nicht abgefedert werden von russland
weißrussland genau soll die ukraine auch
einen marshall plan braucht also einen
einen
neuaufbau
unter der aufsicht der will gemeinschaft
weil wir gesehen haben dass also allein
funktioniert es nicht dass es ich weiß
nicht liegt es an
infantiles muss der bevölkerung oder an
einer besonders komplizierten geschichte
aber nein das funktioniert nicht und
dann diese funktionen sehe ich auch das
besondere dass es diesmal gar nicht so
sehr die staaten sind sondern eben
privatpersonen firmen betriebe die
einfach mit dieser materie nichts zu tun
haben wollen sie die alle die über 30
300 firmen aus russland verlassen haben
die abend das nicht auf anweisung des
amerikanischen präsidenten gemacht
sondern aus ihrer das war ihre freie
entscheidung und so etwas hat es in der
welt noch nie gegeben eine solche
abneigung regime gegenüber
das mittel wissenschaften ist natürlich
problematisch dass das ist keine
unabhängige wissenschaft gibt dann los
und da sind alle staatlich instituten
und diese ist die duden haben
ja eine loyalität geschworen
dem russischen präsidenten der gerade an
diesen kreuzzug gegen den westen gegen
freiheit und demokratie führt also sie
und sie
irgendwie in seinen in seiner armee in
seinen reihen und er hat sie alle
mitgenommen
dieser kleine mann der hat sehr viele
menschen mitgenommen auf eine kreuzung
wenn sie eigentlich natürlich nicht
wollten und nicht brauchten das ist eine
einer
blamage ja die russische wirtschaft
vorstellte da würde ich gern noch mal
einen haken man muss sich sehr genau
anschauen mit wem man kooperiert
da würde ich auch mitgehen und würde
sagen natürlich es gibt diese briefe der
russischen direktorin der der
forschungseinrichtungen die sich hinter
putin stellen es gibt aber auch sehr
sehr große
unterschriftenlisten beispielsweise von
kino von von großen kaderschmieden der
russischen außenpolitik bei denen sich
tausende von alumni dieser starken
organisationen gegen den krieg gestellt
haben es gibt beides man muss schauen
mit wem man kooperiert aber die die
lehre aus dem kalten krieg die lehre aus
der konfliktforschung ist wenn man den
kontakt abbricht ist dass auf lange
sicht nicht friedens fördernd und ich
frage mich auf der anderen seite was ist
die post putin ära ich sehe die noch
nicht ich sehe ich sehe eine nach putin
ära nicht als notwendig positiv wir
wissen auch aus
analogen fällen dass ein staatsstreich
einen umbruch in russland noch
negativere folgen nach sich ziehen
könnte als solche sind anfällig da sind
noch immer wird ich halte es für möglich
dass es schlimmer wird wir haben einen
riesen hatten start mit einem großen
nuklearen chemischen biologischen
arsenal es ist eine hochrisiko variante
jetzt
darüber nachzudenken wie es in einer
post putin gesellschaft aussehen könnte
weil wir überhaupt nicht wissen wie das
politische system darum sich wieder
aufbauen würde ob es ein start wäre ob
es zerfallen der oligopole wären das
wäre extrem riskant das heißt es gibt
relativ wenig hoffnung moment oder grund
zur hoffnung dass sich zum besseren
wendet oder zumindestens in schritten
besser wird es ist wirklich eine eine
düstere situation aber wir haben
sanktionen die robustesten sanktionen
die in der geschichte der europäischen
union wir haben einen krieg der nicht so
läuft wie putin sich das vorgestellt hat
und wir haben über zeitung mit
mittelfristig meine ich auch nicht drei
jahre die möglichkeit dass sich die
kalkulation bei der russischen elite und
bei putin ändern muss weil er einfach
diese militärische eskalation nicht mehr
aufrechterhalten kann wir wissen dass
wenn armeen erschöpft sind das dann
verhandlungen more likely also
wahrscheinlicher werden und das kann in
diesem fall auch in den nächsten wochen
passieren gut das ist viel stochern im
nebel das ist viel spekulation wir sind
selbst nicht genau die entwicklung ist
sehr unsicher ich bedanke mich stand an
dieser stelle müssen wir leider die
diskussion beenden bei seiner
schulden bei angießen und bei wladimir
kaminer liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde krieg corona klima woher
soll das geld kommen es geht um die
laufen der haushaltsdebatte in dieser
woche morgen ist die generaldebatte da
geht es ja um die politik des
bundeskanzlers und aus diesem anlass
unser thema jetzt folgt phoenix der tag
mit alpha-tier thema unter anderem ein
interview mit dem russischen präsidenten
wolodimir zilliken bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]